the community still reeling tonight from
that horrific crash that happened up in
north las vegas saturday
nine people were killed including gary
dean robinson who police say was driving
100 miles per hour causing that crash we
have team coverage tonight victoria saha
spoke with the family of a woman
recovering from the wreck but we begin
with madison kimbrough who was at a
vigil for the man riding with robinson
tonight a vigil for tanaga miller miller
was riding in the passenger seat when he
was killed on saturday right here on
cheyenne and commerce his family
speaking out for the first time after
learning the news of his passing
i just want to say i'm so sorry to the
other families they got hurt out there
the same time my son did a family in
mourning like so many across the valley
after a horrific crash of those that
passed was this man 46 year old tanaga
miller miller was in the passenger seat
of the dodge challenger that ran the red
light on cheyenne and commerce miller's
family is describing him as a fun-loving
people person who was known within his
community it feels really surreal for
all of us and
we're all trying to find a way to cope
with it and to
understand why did this happen he was
recovering himself he was unable to
drive and he probably could do little to
anything to stop the car from going how
it was monday family and friends
gathered here at valley view park in
north las vegas purple and white
balloons could be seen from all around
along with candles laying out miller's
nickname tealoak as for the driver of
the dodge challenger miller's sister
says she didn't know him but urges the
las vegas community to take the time to
watch where they're going so something
like this doesn't happen to them slow
down people that's all i got to say slow
down
we don't need to be in a rush and leave
early enough where you don't have to
speed
and miller's sister has set up a
gofundme page for her brother's funeral
expenses we will have a link attached to
this story up on our website as you can
see this is a very busy roadway so we're
wishing the best for this family
reporting live madison kimbrough live
local now